when my cue comes call me and I will
answer my next is most fair Pyramus man
Oh Peter quince flute the Bellas meander
it's not the tinker startling God's my
life storm Hinson left me asleep I've
had a most rare vision had a dream past
the wit of man to zero dream it was man
is but an ass if he go about to expound
this dream meet our times there is no
man can say what
we thought of us Hannah me Trotter him
but man is but a patched fool if he will
offer to say what we thought ahead the
eye of men had not heard the ear of man
hath not seen men's hand is not able to
taste his tongue to conceive or is her
to report what my dream was
I will get Peter quince to write a
ballad of this dream and it shall be
called Barton's dream because it hath no
bottom and habited in the latter end of
a plane before the joke / adventure to
make it more gracious I will sing it at
her death